hello my awesome tacular right sorry
this is a new segment I've wanted to do
for quite some time I don't know if I'm
just doing it one time I don't know if
I'm doing it many times I don't know if
I'm doing it weekly that's all up to you
I suppose but ultimately I get a lot of
comments and I don't address them all
thing to know is all of the comments
you're about to see are actually real
and they are from my thor ragnarok
review so i'm going to call this and
help make it feel a bit more real we
have douchey version of me re-enacting
the comments that's not douchey me yeah
douchey you it's you alright do see me
in a hoodie there we go so let's begin
this is the best Thor film yet well
right the first to sell it enough in the
seconds the worst Marvel film well funny
thing is I never actually said this is
the best Thor film yet granted you could
be quoting someone else on my page or on
the comments section of my video but you
can see how you get confusing but in
essence never actually said that your
fanboys can't fish reality this movie is
complete [ __ ] losers it was fun I didn't
say it was Macbeth or anything like that
I'm pretty sure we can agree my review
was pretty fair pretty objective another
Marvel [ __ ] boy chill or not does Jeremy
work with DC now this is the only review
that said Thor was not amazing wait I
thought it was a Marvel [ __ ] boy shell
like am i bought by Marvel and DC
because I'm really confused right now
and if you're right I'm really rich -
Jeremy Jones is the Michael Bay of movie
reviewers it is ironic when you think
about it when you think of the first
video life
how can critics like this if it's
incoherent and tone and bash BBS the are
clearly biased well I can't speak for
other people on here I can only speak
for myself but I never said thor
ragnarok was incoherent in tone I said
it had tonal discrepancies and tonal
differences throughout but I'd never
said it was incoherent I also never said
that Batman vs Superman was incoherent
in tone my gripes with Batman vs
Superman had to do with structure the
structure and editing of
as a whole not tone I thought the tone
was fine at exactly 131 Jeremy hits
puberty what he's in he really does
steal it I've known for a long time
Jeremy is like a [ __ ] for MCU movies
and we're like every MCU movie no matter
what yeah someone didn't wash my review
of Iron Man 2 or guardians of the galaxy
2 didn't jerk those movies off but I
didn't even watch this video and gave it
a dislike just because of the thumbnail
image how do you say that if you haven't
seen it I just I what I was just trying
to be cool and thumb no I wanted to be
like Raiden I wanted to be Raiden dick
that thumbnail though Jeremy turned into
Raiden Oh mark he gets it
well I just liked this video just
because of the joke at the beginning the
joke too I mean you can't dislike a
video if the person who made the joke in
the video awkwardly walks off frame
addressing the fact that the joke in the
video is actually a bad joke I mean
disliking it at that point that's just
bad form unless you're saying you
personally dislike it not in the
thumbs-down context but you just dislike
the video because of the joke which case
a bad ninety-eight percent on Rotten
Tomatoes and it's not even worth buying
on blu-ray
well Rotten Tomatoes works a little
differently like that the percentage of
the tomato meter is based on the
percentage of critics who actually like
the movie which is 60 percent or higher
not the average rating of all critics
like example if 100 percent of critics
say the movie is a 60 percent out of a
hundred then that 60 percent out of the
hundred average movie has a tomato meter
rating of 100 percent because 100
percent of critics liked it that's how
it works the phrase should have been
whoa
you said thor ragnarok was fun and it
has a 98% of Rotten Tomatoes makes sense
that way well I personally think Captain
America's a most boring Avenger Thor is
like God after all but oh it's true it's
all about your personal preference of
what you would find interesting but I'm
just saying like you look at Superman
Superman is basically a god or at least
a demigod at least to us he has godlike
powers Batman doesn't have that so
Batman is not a god
to Superman but if you choose Batman or
Superman I'm going to find a
conversation with Batman probably more
interesting than Superman
so the diety factor doesn't really play
into it all I was saying is that Thor
generally speaking comes across as more
boring than say Tony Stark I'd rather
have a conversation with him so it's
just kind of funny that they made him a
comedian now thanks for delivering a
good review that doesn't suck the movies
dick well thanks as always just giving
my honest opinion
how much did Marvel pay to suck their
dicks I'm really confused still better
than Suicide Squad yeah and this dude
gave that [ __ ] pile the same rating as
Blade Runner 20 49 and a better rating
than alien I don't trust this guy at all
I just watched your Suicide Squad review
again oh you got a minute burn it on
blu-ray and watching it haha
no thanks okay just back away alright
just back away alright so I enjoyed
Suicide Squad I enjoyed a shitty movie
called Suicide Squad and I was a bit
nicer to it than I probably should have
been in my review and yeah maybe the
movie doesn't really hold up after a
couple of viewings sorry about that I
had fun with it I was nice to it in my
perception hey it's just one review it's
not like it's gonna follow me around for
the rest of my life so now that we know
can we just stop talking about it
like forever that cool awesome thank you
unreal that this gets a lower grade than
Suicide Squad oh my god alright so
that's it for the first I guess episode
or edition of tales from the comments
section still ironing it out I kind of
see where I want it to go but it's
definitely not perfect right here but if
anyone wants to do something on YouTube
my best advice for them is don't wait to
perfect it before you do it because then
you'll never do it you do it and then
you earn it out as you go so hopefully
you enjoyed it it's just I see some
crazy comments and instead of commenting
in the comments section it might as well
just make a video about it so here we
are so let me know what you think let's
pass it around always taking some
feedback here I'd like for there to be a
second episode of this if you liked it
show it to your friends and get that to
happen and as always if you like what
you've seen
you want to see more click right here to
see more I liked the review look thanks
I appreciate that but then gave it a
down vote just for the joke Oh what the
[ __ ]
[Music]